[Musique]
si nous mesurons les contraintes
n'avions pas d'autre choix car c'était
cela ou la fermeture du pays c'était
cela ou de nouveau couvre-feu de nouveau
confinement de nouvelles fermetures
comme on commence à le faire aux
antilles comme d'autres territoires
d'ailleurs commence aujourd'hui à le
faire nous agissons toujours avec le
même esprit être proportionnée et
compter sur la responsabilité de chacun
au sein de la nation que chacun se
souvienne que quand il n'y avait plus de
chiffre d'affaires du tout à cause de
l'épidémie
ces liens l'argent public qui a permis
de rémunérer les responsables de ces
lieux comme leurs salariés il est donc
légitime comme on le fait d'ailleurs
pour beaucoup d'autres risquent de
demander une part de responsabilité à
ses gestionnaires loin de ce
qu'affirment certains et qui font
commerce de cette pandémie pour gagner
des parts de marché politique jamais
dans notre histoire une crise d'une
telle ampleur n'a été combattu de
manière aussi démocratique nous avons
rendu public toutes les données dont
nous disposions sur lesquelles nous
fondons nos décisions nous avons pris
les décisions et c'est ce qui est
attendu de celles et ceux qui président
les gouvernent ces décisions ont ensuite
suivi un chemin démocratique normal avec
des débats parlementaires nourris et des
dizaines d'heures de débats de jour
comme de nuit elles ont ensuite donné
lieu à un contrôle constitutionnel comme
il se doit et des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel qui s'est mobilisée lui
aussi dans cette période notre objectif
et d'objectifs que je vous fixe est donc
très simple c'est la vaccination de tous
les français qui peuvent être vaccinés
nous sommes à cet égard en bonne voie
nous avons ces dernières semaines marqué
une très forte accélération de notre
vaccination nous avons plus de 45
millions de françaises et de français
45,3 exactement à date qui ont reçu au
moins une dose autant de témoins il
s'agit de solutions parfaitement sûr et
nous avons près de 38 millions 37,8 pour
être précis qui ont ce qu'on appelle un
schéma vaccinal complet
[Musique]
oh